To calculate what direction we're firing, the first thing we need to do in our
update code, is figure out whether or not the user has pressed one of the fire
keys, fire0 or fire1. Once they have, the next step we need to do is figure out
what the player's position is in screen space. Our render engine actually
defines a function called getScreenPosition. Which will actually project a
world space position into the canvas screen coordinates. What this means is
that we'll now have the player's position in the same coordinate space as our
mouse input. Because the two are now in the same space, we simply need to
subtract the mouse input from the player position to give us an unnormalized
vector. A simple normalized will give us a unit length vector. And we can now
use the directional vector as basis to launch our projectile towards the other
evil, evil robot.